in a small town in the former East
Germany a new york-based startup is
making waves
my name is andy katz mayfield i'm the
co-founder and co-ceo of harry's and
harry's is a grooming brand we sell our
own shaving products razor blade shaving
cream through our website harrys.com
there's a couple of companies that have
controlled the industry for a really
long time and they charge prices that
are pretty disconnected from the cost to
manufacture in january harry's bought
fine technique total cost including a
bit extra to fund expansion one hundred
million dollars
it's an when we started Harry's we
searched all over the world to try to
find the best manufacturer and it turns
out the best manufacturer in the world
is here in Germany we're able to
particularly now owning the factory
deliver product really efficiently to
our customers we also sell directly to
them and by doing that we're able to
deliver it at really exceptional value
you get down here and I mean you walk
through this Factory and you immediately
have an appreciation for how hard it is
to actually manufacture razor blades how
skilled the the workers are here
the folks here have been doing this for
a long time they're truly craftsmen and
that is the special sauce in this
factories the people and the process and
the know-how that enables them to grind
steel and create really high quality
blade